[Music]
do
cool scary eye-opening shot and all but
doesn't that mean you rolled over here
with your eyes closed i know we're
supposed to think he's mr badass scare
guy but the real pros don't take chances
like that just hit the layup kobe and
leave that behind the back nonsense to
the show boaters joe said just in case
re-terrorizing children with scary
monsters doesn't work let's hard shift
into traumaville with a good old visual
of a robot child twitch sparking to
death you mean if i get to monsters
incorporated no
when
spoilers first of all how did you get a
hold of this letter when it's clearly
addressed to him and second why are you
telling him now instead of letting him
find out when he reads it let the kid
have his moment you felonious letter
stealing killjoy also sending a letter
with no return address is just a move
the first line of business for whatever
working monster does must be to overhaul
the efficiency of these pipes at first
glance you'd think they're for liquid or
gas transport with the little valve
doodads and whatnot but this container
means this is a pneumatic tube messaging
system so these odd-shaped curves are
rubbish pipelining did everyone just
happen to buy the same newspaper on the
way into work today or did some troll
bring a whole bunch in just to rub salt
in the wounds it's probably the troll
thing huh can you imagine being the kind
of person that would purposefully draw
attention to the failures of the things
they love i shudder too considerate also
why have they already changed the scare
floors to laugh floors in the movie
sully had that idea on his way home but
by the time the laugh floors were in use
mike had pieced boo's door together
already which he said took him a long
time and his hands were all scarred from
the splinters but it was worth it
because he loves sully so much can we
just go to the next sin already they're
putting you two in charge yep that's how
it works when you're a whistleblower you
get to run the company afterwards that's
why jeffrey wiggin now runs the brown
and williamson tobacco company what was
that joke a bit too inside man
goodbye lip dipping into the receiver of
a handheld phone monsters incorporated
this cecilia may i no longer answer the
phones goodbye answering the phone to
say you're not answering the phone
directly followed by disconnecting the
call before doing anything related to
the reason one would answer the phone in
the first place so tyler tuskman talks
to celia while she's on the phone and
honestly this gag happens a lot in
movies and television and it's an
absolute sin there's only one type of
person who would actually approach
someone on the phone and start yammering
on as if they're more important so the
sin as always is kids
proceed to perform your humorous
dissertation okay this will be the last
time i mention it but it bears repeating
how did they completely retrofit the
scare simulation to laughter seemingly
overnight you're trying to squeeze humor
out of it both being so soon that tyler
doesn't know his position has changed
and also being long enough to convert
everything to laughs and just like the
title of my sex tape you can't have it
both ways
funny
the issue of scaring children for power
is the same issue for laughs it's all
interpreted differently and clearly this
child has a very odd sense of humor
given this horrific drawing of a
by-headed horse monster pooping a
butterfly
tickling someone else's child without
explicit consent open containers on top
of important equipment i don't want to
be at hat racks i just could really only
hold two hats excuse me for challenging
the facts of what is obviously a very
real attempt at finding this young
gentleman a job as a hat rack in a place
where monsters only wear helmets when it
work but don't have regular hats to hang
up anyway but if the hats had those
adjustable clicky things you actually
could string several of them on his
horns you know what this is why i was
fired from zip recruiter guess i'll have
to get a job at monster.com hey wait a
minute
but why would these letters be so
crooked not really the whole regimented
stuffed shirt college scene type of gal
stuffed shirt how about any shirt all of
these monsters running around completely
nude and i'm here having to figure out
if that means they don't have genitals
and if they did where would they be and
what would they look like and where does
the body hair in and the pubic hair
begin then contemplating different
possible sexual positions for different
monsters in uh am i still saying all
this out loud yeah after mu i lived in
the caribbean for a year why would
everything in this world have scary
words in the name most of our world runs
on fossil fuels but you don't see places
named colifornia or electricity or the
earth is doomed if we don't find cleaner
energy in the next 30 years ona in a
world of oddly shaped monsters it just
seems that perhaps an inclusive
workplace would have chairs to better
represent the needs of all the variety
of bums that would use them how is this
monster supposed to scoot herself into
the chairs unblinking eye contact while
touching baked goods sorry what exactly
is mifft is the first question you would
have asked mr crummiham when he was
assigning your job or val in the several
minutes it took to get over here but
sure you're just now curious about your
brand new vocation standing on a chair
with wheels do you want head trauma
because this is how you get head trauma
proud to be a member of the monsters inc
facilities team since i've learned that
gif must be pronounced with a hard g
because it stands for graphic i've made
it my life's work to teach others proper
acronym pronunciation this one's tricky
because if you say the full word
incorporated then miffed works just fine
but he doesn't he says monsters inc
facilities team so meeped it is and
meefed it shall always be
[Music]
for the record i've never actually said
that for the record we're all wondering
where the confetti came from because it
wasn't in your hand a moment ago thanks
but i'm not really family i could be to
you like a father figure mistaking the
transactional nature of a job with the
familiarity of the family bond you can
have positive working relationships with
your coworkers without pretending like
they share genetic code i promise you
don't have my phone number i can get it
out of your employee file stalking drink
this
uh oh uh thanks drinking unknown
substances without question twice you
and me we see eye to eyes but you both
have eyes this is a dumb joke tyler has
two eyes two if you were a cyclops your
joke is still not funny but at least it
makes factual sense i didn't have enough
time to make a new sign but you do have
a double-sided whiteboard that could
easily act as a welcome sign shut up he
can still hear you smitty and needleman
would be excellent at tv since this
massively obvious sneak by a massively
obvious monster is massively convenient
hardy har horny boy got his horny horns
horned into some clipboards but how
you're telling me that he not only just
happened to fall where these two
clipboards were perfectly spaced at the
length of his horns but they also
somehow hooked into those tiny holes and
didn't fall off when he got up what is
this some sort of cartoon show also how
long does it take for someone to walk
from downstairs to the scare floor tyler
left around this time which seems to be
about two-ish and now it's 4 30. caring
about planets this much this kid is
scared out of his mind and decides to
walk nicely over to his closet why did
he go from terrified to curious so fast
when he wasn't even awake when tusman
came through it
[Music]
throwing poo
welcome to monsters incorporated
roll come on stir shells wait he dug
this letter out of the trash how do you
know where to look and why is it still
so clean you know what kind of filth is
in the dumpster at a place where
monsters work no well just ask the
janitors at monsanto corporate
headquarters
you think you could do these things but
you just can't i can really get into
this being in charge
all day long
maybe i can tell you a joke three
tomatoes are walking down the street
papa tomato mama tomato and baby tomato
i don't want you to take this the wrong
way but i hate you i brought a peeled
banana in this flower that emits liquids
you be careful
don't you break a nail
[Music]
hi everyone just to be clear never have
i ever
eaten human flesh
inspired
you can quit right now and everything
that we worked for will have been
accomplished
you know last night molly said to me on
the phone that you thought i was your
hero
you're mine
david got his horn caught the door track
was pulled into a shredder shaft never
saw him again and i guess that was your
accomplice and the wood chipper